the doctor said to me Lindsay you're
gonna need to watch out for signs of
rabies which apparently increased
irritation foaming at the mouth and
extreme anger I was like Doc I'm pretty
sure I've had gravy since I was four
years old
her comedy is described as take no
prisoners it is a lot of fun she will
skewer everyone everything but in a good
way and she is performing at the Wise
Guys Comedy Club next week welcome
Lindsey Glazer back to the show thanks
so much for being here thank you for
having me so excited for you because
you've been doing great you sold out the
last time you're expected to sell out
again and this is not necessarily how
you started as far as a career is
concerned you were an attorney I was so
technically I am still an attorney but
it's the same skill builds performance
and all jobs are a sales job
you do it well I mentioned that you
skewer everything everybody but you walk
that fine line that make comedians
really funny in that it's not over the
top mean spirited
some people would say it's not over the
top mean spirited maybe not for daytime
TV well you are the alpha B yes right we
won't say here but hear the alphabet
yeah so you do have an edge to you and
people should know that going in but
much like Don Rickles was able to skewer
people and let them know at the same
time okay it's still okay you know
things are okay that's right we only
roast the ones we love right right have
you have uh gotten a lot of your comedy
from your daughter who's now nine years
old right yes she's nine years old she's
a firecracker as they would say she got
in trouble last week and I told her I
don't like you or your behavior very
much and she yelled at me it's not my
job to make you like me it's my job to
like myself there's too much wisdom in
that that's scary I was like angry and
proud at the same time well now you seem
likable to me we had a chance to talk
ahead of time but your daughter uh has a
friend who thinks otherwise right she
told me after I said that to her that
this is why my imaginary friend doesn't
like you I said excuse me and she said
yeah she thinks you're too self-absorbed
and I said your imaginary friend that
you made up because I'm self-absorbed I
said vain yes in vain and possibly
bipolar that's fantastic all right but
Kendall I asked her I said hey out of
curiosity what's your imaginary friend's
name she said Grandma
[Laughter]
you were in the public Spotlight for a
bizarre reason oh that's right yeah
Scottie Pippen went after you he did
Scottie Pippen sued me I lived in this
house my house was ruined in a hurricane
in Florida uh Scottie Pippen sued me
because he thought it was related to
Malcolm Glazer who the former passed
away owner of the Tampa Bay Bucs thought
you had billions of dollars instead of
yeah whatever instead of you know fives
and ten yeah exactly how did that end or
how did it come to a conclusion well how
it ended was Scottie Pippen tried to get
me to send sign an NDA saying I want to
talk about it so he could go on TV and
talk about the last dance in his book
settling scores if you come to the show
you'll see how he did it I'll tell you
all about it oh my gosh that's great we
do want to tell people about where the
show is and we also want to tell people
that you have a place in your heart for
military and there's a special deal for
them at your show yeah that's right if
you are military and you can prove it
your first drink is on us the show is
actually at Wise Guys Comedy Club
located in the arts district it's 1511
South Main Street you can get your
tickets by going to the website which is
vegas.wiseguys.com all right let's
review that again Lindsay thanks for
joining us she is going to be at Wise
Guys comedy club that's the 16th and
17th of this month and you can go to
vegas.wiseguyscomedy.com right that's
right and they do have the special offer
that we talked about if you're in the
mail military and can prove it you get
your first drink for free Lindsay it's
always fun to have you here thank you so
much thanks so much